la ville de montréal réexamine sa
décision de déverser directement dans le
fleuve des milliards de litres d'eaux
usées on n'exagère pas exactement à peu
près la quantité que l'on déverserait
dans le fleuve
la ville avait prévu sept jours de
déversement la mi octobre afin de
construire une nouvelle chute à neige
près de l'autoroute bonaventure
la décision finale sera annoncée demain
à 11 heures
mais cette décision avait fait bondir
daniel green environnementalistes vous
le connaissez chef adjoint du parti vert
du canada est candidat dans la
circonscription ville-marie le sud ouest
ile des soeurs
monsieur green on vous a presque demandé
d'aller vous baigner parce que vous êtes
allé le des soeurs à 3,1 mètres de l'eau
racontez moi ce qui si horrible donc on
déverse frais pendant sept jours des
eaux d'égout quoi effectivement alors
donc justement un total de prévoyance la
ville de montréal on aurait pu prévoir
le coup déverser des eaux non traitées
desu qui contiennent des coliformes
fécaux des eaux qui contiennent même des
rejets des industries dans les parcs
industriels de la salle de verdun et
donc de tout le sud-ouest des vaccins
directement dans le dans le fleuve saint
laurent sans aucun traitement en 2015
c'est cesser c'est incroyable la ville
de marennes qu'elle ait fait savoir le
coup parce que c'est bon il ya une
époque on faisait ça m'allait besoin
mais quel effet sept jours du
déversement peut avoir est ce que la
qualité vraiment du fleuve pendant
plusieurs jours et est atteint
absolument écouter quand il ya une
surverse quand il tombe 22 20
millimètres de pluie tout le littoral
justement du sud-ouest du sénat rend sur
l'île de montréal est contaminée il y a
même on ferme même le canal de lachine
en a 72 heures après un petit
déversement alors là on parle d'un méga
déversement alors qui va contaminer tous
les littérale de l'est de montréal
du côté sud sud est sud ouest il va
falloir avertir les citoyens de ne pas
toucher l'eau parce que les
concentrations élevées à ce point il que
simplement toucher à l'eau est porté ses
doigts à sa bouche c'est assez on peut
avoir assez de coliformes pour cause
d'une vilaine gastro entérite
alors j'espère que la ville de montréal
vont au moins mettre de l'affichage et
les citoyens vont le voir on sait qu il
convient d deux versements de dégoût
on peut détecter les scellés versement
par l'accumulation d'applicateurs tampon
et de condom le long du littoral c'est
un éducation qui est une surverse dégoût
et là il va en sortir des condoms lors
de ce déversement dans les eaux qui
baignent morère où j'avais même dit que
vous ne laisseriez pas votre chien boire
l'eau du fleuve lors qu'ils ont un
système de filtration les chiens oui
c'est sûr mais c'est peut-être plus
dangereux que de toucher le chien qui
est des coliformes jenson poil là et là
donc
donc il nous faut éviter de toucher
l'eau donc un avis aux pêcheurs aux gens
qui sont du surf dans la vague
stationnaire devant habitat 67
évidemment les les il faut surtout pas
se baigner dans l'eau et même se
promener sur la bord de l'eau ne pas
toucher l'eau il est même le rivage qui
aurait pu être contaminés par ces eaux
contaminées dernière green la ville
répond puis on attendra demain aux
armées ce que l'on compensé qu'elle va
nous dire qu'elle n'a pas le choix que
dans la construction puis on ya un
séjour qui a pas d'autre manière de
procéder
qu'est ce que vous répondez oui fixe bah
écoutez il ya d'autres manières de
procéder de 1,10 aurait pu prévoir le
coup à 20 ne veut pas croire que des
ingénieurs intelligent ne pourrait pas
construire une chute à neige en même
temps que l'eau circule dans un égout
peut-être avec un autre design et si
c'est impossible ici il faut
effectivement
travailler à sec on aurait pu divertir
les égouts du collecteur sud là où lang
se trouvent nos égouts dans une unité
mobile de d'épuration des eaux
il existe oui ça coûterait cher mais au
moins on arrêterait de traiter notre
fleuve saint-laurent comme un égout
facile où on peut déverser n'importe où
n'importe quand ce green je vous donne
20 secondes c'est terminé
malheureusement votre campagne le parti
vert au québec quel bilan vous en faites
pour terminer mais quand même est-ce que
les gens sont curieux voix effectivement
on a beaucoup d'appuis les différents
candidats verts à travers le québec pour
une fois on fait vraiment campagne on a
une offre intéressante
c'est sûr qu'on parle de pipelines de
déversement d'eau dans le fleuve
saint-laurent un parti vert est
nécessaire pour la démocratie dans le
pays
daniel green bonne fin de campagne à
vous à la première fille au revoir